since the pandemic started i feel like
i always say this like i feel like it
helped
with
the bars
in terms of
fans
wanting that or wanting more substance
or wanting more from music because
[ __ ] weren't in the club
standing on couches popping bottles so
you saw
benny and wes saigon and freddy gibbs
all these people have the best years of
their career royce the five nine was
nominated for a grammy you know what i'm
saying like do you feel like that the
pandemic helped kind of like correct
the path that hip-hop was on because it
feels like absolutely man absolutely
that's
listen everything has his psycho facts
you know so it was already gearing back
towards the lyric driven
music and the stuff
that i'm sure me and you grew up
listening to um
but the pandemic pushed it forward like
a little like made it
rapidly and and speed up the process
yeah and um it's great great timing for
you man i never stopped doing this i
mean even when people were snapping
their fingers bouncing i i was always
doing this type of music man and the
people know that and and and and they
respect me the transparency and when you
[ __ ] continuously do something no
matter what if you show consistency and
just keep at it
something's going to happen out of it in
a positive manner